going back to the jeopardy thing just
what does this opportunity mean to you
to get to host it and what has that show
meant to you over the years i'm really
excited about it we've been uh talking
about it for a little bit
i think i may have jumped the gun a
little bit so i apologize to jeopardy if
they wanted to announce it i just got so
excited on the show earlier
it kind of just went down the last
couple days that's let's figure it out
so
it is very exciting it's for the off
season we'll be even more excited
when that opportunity gets a little
closer but man the show has been so
special to me over the years it's been a
staple
at my house here in green bay for the
last 16 years
guys like mike florio i mean don't waste
your time
reading uh reading crap like that
i have a feeling that will not be a
video
daily double at any point over there
don't read that crap don't read that
crap
have a feeling hey i'm rooting for him
to do well i can't wait to watch it i
hope he does well and uh for business
purposes i'm hoping that it creates a
real conundrum and he has to decide
whether or not he's going to keep
playing oh i bet you would i bet post of
jeopardy i just think it'd be a hell of
a story i always root for a great story
and that would be an incredible story
although packers fans would not be
thrilled with that development the front
office maybe because it definitely would
start the jordan love era in green bay
all right we're gonna do a draft of the
nfl figures who would make the best show
host and that is a very very broad
category both ways we didn't say what
type of show doesn't have to be a game
show it can be any show other than
obviously a sports show trivia question
is going to be jeopardy style so the
answer chris
must be in the form
of a question
the answer is this
the category is presidents okay the
answer is this the answer though
this is the answer you have to give the
question the answer is in the form of a
question here's the answer he received
contract offers from the lions and the
packers to play in the national football
league
uh
who is ronald reagan
gerald ford gerald ford i did i don't
know i did not know that about him wow
he had a reputation for being clumsy he
actually played college football at
michigan wow was an actual jeopardy
question so uh credit to jeopardy for
that
there's a lot of different ways i can go
and some of these guys when we get into
things football figures can do away from
football that would be fun i think some
of the same names are going to come up
and i'm taking him now right out of the
gates bruce erians because whatever it
is you give him whatever he happens to
be drinking you get him to loosen up you
put him behind the desk i would say some
sort of a late night late late night
talk show with relaxed language
standards i think bruce arians would be
awesome as an interviewer monologue he
just you know just talk about just tell
stories and uh and let the profanities
fly it would probably have to be an hbo
show but still i would line up to watch
bruce arians hosting whatever it is he
would want to host no i hear you i mean
yes and you'd like it to be let you know
four letter words fly and everything
like that so he could really feel
himself and be himself that would be
must watch tv so i'm i'm with you there
he was on my list too i'm going to go
with a coach to to go along with you i'm
thinking more of like jeopardy all right
here this is what i'm doing but i am
going to go with my old coach yeah john
gruden i mean if john gruden was the
host of jeopardy the faces you would get
when people answered things wrong and
like had bad answers you know if they
were like what is ronald reagan he'd you
know he'd look at you and what are you
adult or something i mean well ronald
reagan holy cow you don't study he'd
eviscerate these people he wouldn't be
able to hold his emotions so uh gruden
would be one i'd i'd like to sit there
and watch especially host jeopardy
his reactions to when people get the
questions wrong would be worth it yeah
even if he didn't say anything he can't
control his face and he'd have the one
eyebrow flying up and he'd be yeah he
would be very good at that i'm gonna go
next
and this one may surprise you because
he's he's young in the sport yeah but
we've seen enough already from patrick
holmes number one to know and this
applies to all the i took one of yours
all the quarterbacks out there who are
great at what they do would be great at
whatever they do because you have to be
driven and focused and organized and you
have to be a leader and you have to
communicate well patrick holmes is just
so damn likable and i could see him
hosting some sort of a news show where
you know you just get to the news and
all the personality driven stuff that
gets people
polarized there's nothing polarizing
about patrick mahomes he can have the
most difficult delicate subject matter
and he'd deliver everything in such a
likable way that we would get past the
personality and actually get i i know
this is deeper than i wanted to be on
going
but i think he would be a great voice
to cut through all the noise that we now
have to deal with
to get to reality and to understand
issues and and to understand what's
right and what's wrong and i just think
he could do anything
and
and do it in a way
that would work because everyone would
like him he would not be polarizing so
he'd be the perfect figure for anything
where you're trying to bring people
together not drive people apart yeah i i
hear that he does he's got a great way
about him where you would feel like it's
not like uh condescending condescending
or he's shouting down at you or anything
like that plus like you talk about his
voice i'd love to hear his voice that
that'd be the funny thing like doing
jeopardy and anything like that i i
guess i can't do his his kermit the frog
voice but it would be perfect it'd be
fun to watch or listen to uh nonetheless
as quirky as that is so i hear you i'm
mad you took patrick mahomes because
that was going to be one of my choices
all right i'm gonna go i'm gonna go to
jaylen ramsey as my next one i love
jadelyn ramsey i love his like his
surliness
you know his he's got charisma but he's
not afraid to side-eye you and i
certainly think like in a jeopardy
setting too if you had dumb questions oh
man would you get some reactions
facially and some like some crap talking
this is one of the greatest crap talkers
in football so i think he would you know
give it back to some people that way
jalen ramsay to me is like one of those
personalities i'd love to be around for
like a 24-hour period just to hang out
with and hear how his mind works a
little bit i find him intriguing
so you've got him pegged for a jeopardy
ty you you didn't kind of went
on the back and they're all jeopardy
hosts are they pretty yes i kind of went
all jeopardy i mean yes i saw aaron
rodgers on there and i just thought okay
host and i thought it was jeopardy-ish
so that's where i went with this whole
thing
all right well i i got real creative for
my last one i want dan campbell to be
the host of a cooking show specifically
a show about cooking meat on the bone so
we would have as many possible kneecap
biting references as we could get but i
could just see him being like an
in-your-face you know gordon ramsay type
of a figure just yelling and screaming
and especially when it comes to his food
being messed up i have a feeling he's
very particular about his food being
just the way he wants it which is like
full of fat and greasy but but i think
dan campbell based upon what i've seen
and heard of him so far would be awesome
in that kind of a sense well you're
going to get crazy phrases you know who
knows what kind of reactions he's
probably going to give you like life
less lessons on how to be tougher you
know how to work harder do those type of
things old school football talk like
that way
i'm with you i'm really excited about
dan campbell as the coach of the lions i
do i want to see what he brings to that
football team
the way it worked that first time around
with the dolphins uh it was pretty damn
good he did change the energy of that
football team i think he could do that
with detroit my last one is like all
right this was like off my jeopardy one
just because i thought of this this
morning would be
i'd love to see
like uh calais campbell hosting an
interview show you know with like small
hollywood actors that would be hilarious
to see them like right next to each
other in like two cat and then there's
this giant calais campbell and he's
talking to tom cruise who's as big as
his right leg like that that to me would
be must-see and then him talking in his
his big deep voice and he'd be like tom
cruise what did you think of what were
you thinking when you were in all those
movies jumping out of play like that
that i just think would be funny from
the optics although i think it's camp i
think coleas campbell did something like
that where he had like an interview show
with with small furniture
which made his size even more
exaggerated
i haven't seen that
there's plenty of others i had others on
my list i'd like to see bill belichick
do it just because i'd like to see how
he acts in a setting other than when he
is being asked questions he doesn't want
to answer we know he was awesome on that
nfl 100 show and he nominated right the
nfl 100 show and another type of a guy
who
you tell him
the path to being successful he'll
figure it out and he'll do what he has
to do to be successful and i i've heard
this for 20 years you get him away from
football you get him away from that
setting and he's a completely different
guy yeah i mean he is and not that i've
gotten to see it a whole lot myself but
uh
that's anybody that's been around him
for periods of time i mean my father
included all that he is he's very very
funny that way you don't get to see the
real bill when it comes to in-season
football talk doing that type of stuff
because he becomes a machine the
curmudgeon machine and there goes
everything as far as personality or
things like that are concerned but uh
there's there's definitely a cooler side
to bill belichick that only a few people
have gotten to really see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports